At its height, the Roman Empire was home to about
30% of the world’s population, and in many ways
it was the pinnacle of human advancement. Its
citizens enjoyed the benefits of central heating,
concrete, double glazing,
banking, international trade,
and upward social mobility.
Rome became the first city in
history with one million inhabitants
and was a center of technological,
legal, and economic progress. An empire impossible
to topple, stable and rich and powerful.
Until it wasn’t anymore. First slowly then
suddenly, the most powerful civilization on earth
collapsed. By civilization, we mean a complex
society where labor is specialized and social
classes emerge and which is ruled by institutions.
Civilisations share a dominant mutual language and
culture and domesticate plants and
animals to feed and sustain large cities,
where they often construct impressive monuments.
Civilization lets us become efficient on large
scales, collect vast amounts of knowledge,
and put human ingenuity and the natural resources
of the world to work. Without civilization,
most people would never have been born. Which
makes it a bit concerning that collapse is
the rule, not the exception. Virtually all
civilizations end, on average after 340 years.
Collapse is rarely nice for individuals.
Their shared cultural identity is shattered as
institutions lose the power to organize people.
Knowledge is lost, living standards fall, violence
increases and often the population declines.
The civilization either completely disappears,
is absorbed by stronger neighbors
or something new emerges,
sometimes with more primitive
technology than before.
If this is how it has been over
the ages, what about us today?
Just as Europeans forgot how to build
indoor plumbing and make cement,
will we lose our industrial technology,
and with that our greatest achievements,
from one dollar pizza to smartphones or
laser eye surgery? Will all this go away too?
Today our cities stretch for thousands of
square kilometers, we travel the skies,
our communication is instant. Industrial
agriculture with engineered high yield plants,
efficient machinery and high potency fertilizer
feeds billions of people. Modern medicine gives
us the longest lifespan we’ve ever had, while
Industrial technology gives us an unprecedented
level of comfort and abundance – even though
we haven’t yet learned to attain them without
destroying our ecosphere. There are arguably
still different civilizations around today that
compete and coexist with each other, but together
they also form a singular, global civilization.
But this modern, globalized civilization is even
more vulnerable in some ways than past empires,
because we are much more deeply interconnected.
A collapse of the industrialized world literally
means that the majority of people alive today
would perish since without industrial agriculture
we would no longer be able to feed them.
And there is an even greater
risk: What if a collapse were so
deeply destructive that we were
unable to re-industrialize again?
What if it ruined our chances of enjoying a
flourishing future as a multiplanetary species?
A global civilizational collapse
could be an existential catastrophe:
something that ruins not just the
lives of everyone alive today,
but all the future generations that could have
come into being. All the knowledge we might have
discovered, the art we might have created, the
joys we might have experienced, would be lost.
So, how likely is all of this?
Let’s start with some good news. While
civilization collapses have happened regularly,
none have ever derailed the course of
global civilization. Rome collapsed,
but the Aksumite Empire or the Teotihuacans
and of course the Byzantine Empire, carried on.
What about sudden population crashes?
So far we have not seen a catastrophe
that has killed much more than 10% of the
global population. No pandemic,
no natural disaster, no war.
The last clear example of a rapid global
population decrease was the Black Death,
a pandemic of the bubonic plague in the fourteenth
century that spread across the Middle East and
Europe and killed a third of all Europeans
and about 1/10th of the global population.
If any event was going to cause the
collapse of civilization, that should have
been it. But even the Black Death demonstrates
humanity's resilience more than its fragility.
While the old societies were
massively disrupted in the short term,
the intense loss of human lives and suffering
did little to negatively impact European economic
and technological development in the long run.
Population size recovered within 2 centuries,
and just 2 centuries later, the
Industrial Revolution began.
History is full of incredible recoveries from
horrible tragedies. Take the atomic bombing of
Hiroshima during World War 2. 140,000 people were
killed and 90% of the city was at least partially
incinerated or reduced to rubble. But against all
odds, they made a remarkable recovery! Hiroshima’s
population recovered within a decade, and today
it is a thriving city of 1.2 million people.
None of this made these horrible events any
less horrible for those who lived through them.
But for us as a species, these
signs of resilience are good news.
Why Recovery is Likely Even in the Worst Case
One thing that’s different from historic collapses
is that humanity now has unprecedented destructive
power: Today’s nuclear arsenals are so powerful
that an all-out global war could cause a nuclear
winter and billions of deaths. Our knowledge
of our own biology and how to manipulate it
is getting so advanced that it is becoming
possible to engineer viruses as contagious
as the coronavirus and as deadly
as ebola. Increasingly the risk of
global pandemics is much higher than in the past.
So we may cause a collapse ourselves and it might
be much worse than the things nature has thrown
at us, so far. But if, say 99% of the population
died, would global civilization collapse
forever? Could we recover from such a tragedy?
We have some reasons to be optimistic.
Let’s start with food. There are 1 billion
agricultural workers today so, even if the
global population fell to just 80 million,
it is virtually guaranteed that many
survivors would know how to produce food.
And we don’t need to start at square one because
we could still use modern high-yield crops.
Maize is 10 times bigger than its wild ancestor;
ancient tomatoes were the size of today’s peas.
After agriculture, the next step towards recovery
would be rebuilding industrial capacity,
like power grids and automated manufacturing.
A huge problem is that our economies of scale make
it impossible to just pick up where we left off.
Many of our high tech industries are
only functional because of huge demand
and intensely interconnected supply
chains across different continents.
Even if our infrastructure were left unharmed, we
would make huge steps backwards technologically.
But then again, we are thinking in larger time
frames. Industrialization originally happened
12,000 years after the agricultural revolution. So
if we need to start over after a massive collapse,
it shouldn’t be that hard to re-industrialize,
at least on evolutionary timescales.
There’s a hitch, though. The Industrial
Revolution was fuelled, literally, by burning
easily-accessible coal and we are still very
much reliant on it. If we use it all up today,
aside from making rapid climate change
much worse, we could hinder our ability
to recover from a huge crisis. So we
should stop using easy-to-access coal,
so it can serve as a civilization
insurance in case something bad happens.
Another thing that makes recovery likely is that
we’d probably have most of the information we
need to rebuild civilization. We would certainly
lose a lot of crucial institutional knowledge,
especially on hard drives that nobody could
read or operate anymore. But a lot of the
technological, scientific, and cultural knowledge
stored in the world's 2.6 million libraries,
would survive the catastrophe. The post-collapse
survivors would know what used to be possible,
and they could reverse engineer some
of the tools and machines they’d find.
In conclusion, despite the bleak
prospect of catastrophic threats,
natural or created by ourselves,
there is reason for optimism:
humankind is remarkably resilient, and even in
the case of a global civilizational collapse,
it seems likely that we would be able to recover
– Even if many people were to perish or suffer
immense hardship. Even if we lost cultural
and technological achievements in the process.
But given the stakes, the risks are still
unnervingly high. Nuclear war and dangerous
pandemics threaten the amazing global civilization
we have built. Humanity is like a teenager,
speeding around blind corners, drunk, without
a seat belt. The good news is that it is still
early enough to prepare for and to mitigate
these risks. We just need to actually do it.
We made this video together with Will MacAskill,
a Professor of Philosophy at Oxford and one of
the founders of the effective altruism movement,
which is about doing the most good
you can with your time and money.
Will just published a new book
called What We Owe The Future,
which is about how YOU can positively
impact the long-term future of our
world. If you like Kurzgesagt videos,
the chances are high you will like it!
The book has some pretty
counter intuitive arguments,
like that risks from new technology, such
as AI and synthetic biology, are at least as
grave as those from climate change. Or that
the world doesn’t contain too many people,
but too few. And especially that everyday
actions like recycling or refusing to fly
just aren’t that big a deal compared to
where you donate, or what career you pursue.
Most importantly, it argues
that, by acting wisely,
YOU can help make tomorrow better
than today. And how WE together
can build a flourishing world for the thousands or
millions of generations that will come after us.
Many things we at Kurzgesagt talk about regularly
are discussed here, in much greater detail.
Check out What We Owe The Future wherever
you get your books or audiobooks.
Did we manage to unlock a new fear for you?
Let’s counter existential dread
with appreciation for humanity.
Look how far we’ve come as
a species. What we’ve built
and where we’ve gathered. Let this new World
Map Poster be a reminder of what we can achieve.